good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we've been watching too
much TV again and can't help but notice
that it's a staple of every cable news
show on television pretty much the
battle for the soul of the Republican
Party the other channels are forever
inviting on some discredited neocon
[ __ ] or unemployed political hack to
fret about how the GOP is in a state of
existential crisis the topic is an
entirely phony real rifts do exist
obviously and we cover them but
basically in its totality this is
propaganda because it intentionally
obscures a much larger and far more
interesting story the Democratic Party
is transforming before our eyes the
party of Tom Foley and Tip O'Neill and
even Bill Clinton is long gone pretty
soon the party of Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer will be history too in its place
is emerging something new the party of
Andrew Gilliam Gilliam is the mayor of
Tallahassee as of last night he's the
Democratic nominee for governor of
Florida here's some of what he believes
we want to replace ice with the
Department of Justice okay it's an
entity that has not been tarnished in
the same way as as I said so again nice
oh that's he says you want to abolish
ice you say you want to replace it
that's basically the same do you think
the president should be impeached I
absolutely do I think he's already
incriminating himself by interfering
with the Department of Justice firing
Jim called me of whom I'm no fan of but
basically obstructing justice the state
of Florida has long been considered
moderate politically it's a vital swing
state obviously during presidential
elections many pundits last night and
today even Democrats have been quick to
dismiss Andrew Gilliam chances this fall
he's too far out there saying he's too
much of an outsider that's absurd
they have no idea what they're talking
about they were embarrassingly wrong in
the last election and they have learned
precisely nothing since amazingly
they're still in the predictions
business when they should be selling
aluminum siding or doing something
useful
ignore them of course Andrew Gilliam
could win you ought to be taking his
candidacy very seriously
he's like his erupting in a lot of
places right now the man almost certain
to be governor of the biggest state in
the country just announced the he plans
to give free health care to foreign
nationals here illegally watch I did
universal health care when I was mayor
fully implemented regardless of
pre-existing condition ability pay and
regardless your immigration status San
Francisco is the only universal health
care plan for all undocumented residents
in America I'm very proud of that and we
proved it can be done without
bankrupting in the city I'd like to see
that we can extend that to the rest of
the state so you sneak into a country
ignoring its laws and you get free
health care in return or the country in
New York City meanwhile a City
Councilman named Giovanni Williams is
within striking distance of becoming
that state's next lieutenant governor
you might recognize his name Williams is
a pretty good guy actually he's a
frequent guest on the show he's the one
who's always calling everyone a bigot
who wants to take your guns away and
throw open the borders to the world
we're not exaggerating by the way check
YouTube if you don't believe it
that's him meanwhile in the state of
Arizona the Democratic nominee for
governor David Garcia says he would like
to erase any barrier at all between the
United States and Mexico I want to just
take a second and imagine let's just
imagine just imagine no wall no wall in
southern Arizona Arizona was once one of
the most conservative states politically
in the country now it's a completely
different place
he could win if enough these candidates
do win you won't have to imagine what a
borderless America might look like it'll
be the reality and just the beginning of
the new reality consider this a proposal
from Zephyr Teachout she's a candidate
for attorney general in the state of New
York and as Attorney General I will
continue to speak out against ice I will
prosecute ice for their criminal acts
putting law enforcement in prison for
enforcing the laws that bipartisan
majorities in Congress passed so you
don't need to be a trump partisan or a
conservative Republican or some kind of
wacko right winger to worry about all of
this any normal American ought to be
deeply concerned about what the
Democratic Party is in the process of
becoming a lot of Democrats are very
concerned about